le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais afin de favoriser
l'intégration et l'accès à la vie
économique et sociale des personnes en
situation de handicap une journée
départementale aura lieu à la réunion le
mercredi 11 novembre
notre collectivité a pour mission
l'accompagnement de ce public au
quotidien et a souhaité initier une
démarche volontariste intégrant le
handicap dans sa politique de ressources
humaines
quels sont les axes pour aider à
l'insertion des personnes handicapées
on en parle tout de suite dans lien
social fin 2012 une convention avec le
sip hfp fonds pour l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées dans la fonction publique a
été signé et suite à une campagne de
publicité en 2013 le département a
récolté 1200 candidature à la suite de
quoi
77 personnes en situation de handicap
ont été recrutés entre 2013 et 2014 par
la collectivité
le département au delà de l'obligation
légale souhaite pouvoir réaliser et
maintenir ses efforts dans la durée
alors mon handicap
c'est un handicap visuel alors c'est
suite à un cancer quand j'étais petit ça
s'appelle un sarko que j'ai eu à l'âge
de 5 ans et donc j'ai une ablation
totale de la gauche que au niveau du
recrutement
donc j'ai répondu à l'annoncé que le
département avait fait dans l'est
dans les journaux moi sur mon domaine
c'est l informatique
on m'a sollicité pour faire un entretien
exposer mes qualités
au niveau informatique j'ai fait un
énième entretien avec donc le directeur
de
l'éducation est aussi avec le change de
changer de mission tice afin de voir ce
que je faisais au niveau de mon travail
je suis dans le service des collèges
ça se passe bien une fois que je suis
arrivé et on m'a on m'a donné
les différentes tâches que j'avais à
faire les six premiers mois m'ont permis
surtout d'abord une formation aussi
cette information qui était pour moi le
plus importante parce que il y avait
quand même des domaines je ne
connaissais pas et j'ai appris chaque
joueur j'aime mon travail et j'en
apprends encore tous les jours
j'essaye au mieux et au mieux de moi
même de fournir fournir le meilleur
travail pour que in fine et nos élèves
puissent avoir l'outil informatique
étant donné que j'ai quasiment pas de
champ gauche je dois faire attention à
aux gens qui arrivent à ma gauche donc
là c'est le cas où tout le monde voit
mais généralement j'ai une paire de
lunettes solaires
parce que c'est sûr que quand on sent
dans la rue et que on est défiguré tout
le monde vous regarde moi à l'heure
actuelle je suis passé au delà de tout
ça j'ai dit si j'ai pas mes lunettes je
sors et je vis ma vie je ne suis pas là
pour pour m'apitoyer sur mon sort c'est
quelque chose que je ne veux pas faire
et c'est pas une image non plus que je
veux
que je veux donner c'est pas parce qu'on
est différent qu'on doit être mise à
l'écart c'est vrai que porter un
handicap c'est pas facile tous les jours
surtout avec les enfants et il est vrai
que quand je marche des fois et beaucoup
d'enfants me demande
10 à ses parents me disent ce monsieur
là bas il n'a pas d'oeil
généralement quand il est petit quand il
ya même trois ans quatre ans cinq ans
qui nous pose sa question
je vais vers lui et je lui explique
pourquoi je suis comme ça une fois que
l'explication est finie et que les
enfants vous regardez il faut un grand
sourire c'est là que vous comprenez que
vous avez gagné dans son estime pour
réussir une politique emploi handicap
il faut d'abord une volonté clairement
affichée une volonté politique très
forte au sein de la collectivité
territoriale
il faut aussi donc une bonne
connaissance des dispositifs des
procédures et pour cela bien évidemment
une équipe dédiée et une référente
emploi handicap qui travaille donc en
lien avec la médecine professionnelle
pour appréhender les situations de
manière globale c'est aussi donc mettre
en place un partenariat avec tous les
acteurs qui interviennent dans le dans
le monde du handicap notamment la mdph
le cap emploi mais aussi et surtout la
fit et hfp puisqu'à travers le
conventionnement le département a pu
bénéficier d'un grand nombre d' aide
pour venir
aménager donc les postes de travail mais
aussi et qui fait les agents immobiliers
en matériel et accompagner aussi les
agents dans leurs conditions de travail
se lancer dans cette démarche de
politique emploi handicap ça aussi été
l'occasion pour la direction des
ressources humaines de développer de
nouvelles pratiques de travail puisque
le recrutement d'une personne en
situation de handicap ça dans tous leurs
recrutements pour les compétences mais
c'est aussi donc une approche
individualisée pour prendre en compte la
situation de la personne
ces contraintes travailler aux meilleurs
aménagements possibles de son poste
travailler à une bonne condition pour la
prise de fonction et cela donc nécessite
de nouvelles méthodes nouvelles
pratiques pour la pour la fonction rh
puisque nous devons donc travailler avec
d'autres professionnels pour envisager
des études ergonomiques pour envisager
des achats de mobilier particulier des
partenariats avec des interprètes ou
encore la mise en place de prestation de
compensation du handicap
la collectivité départementale a pour
objectif de poursuivre ses efforts
engagés en faveur de l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes en
situation de handicap
rappelons que nous sommes tous acteurs
d'une société digne de ce nom et qu'il
est important que chacun prenne
conscience de la différence de l'autre
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais